what you doing baby cookie
have you got your stick
yeah
oh
look at this belly
look at this bag
well you're not playing with your stick
anymore
i bought those sticks for you to chew on
so you wouldn't chew on mommy's
microphones
even though you chew on her microphones
anyway
yeah
you just can't handle it anymore
you look like you just can't handle it
this tail is lagging
nope it's not wagging now
make a deal lag what's going on
what are you doing
what are you doing
you're so weird
why are you so weird
why are you so weird
[Laughter]
oh my goodness
look at how funny you are
look at how funny you want
did you fall asleep like that
did you fall asleep like that you did
are you sleeping
no
okay
sorry i interrupted
[Laughter]
those are her cheese sticks y'all
because she chews on
anything metal
like
she chews on microphones she chews on
computer cords or power cords
so i bought her these little sticks that
have catnip on them
from chewy
they do work but she still chews on [ __ ]
she's not supposed to
yeah
okay i'm gonna interrupt your nap